um for you like obviously you've had a
pretty interesting 12 months but really
the last 6 seven months things have
really picked up for you like
um are you feeling that now are you kind
of feeling like okay because I've heard
you have a reputation that you're crazy
I don't know if you know that about
yourself that's what they say lot a
couple of people like hom is crazy he's
really like he really crazy
I I heard that um but I'm wondering like
for you obviously 5 months ago you have
a kid your rap careers flourishing like
crazy are you feeling like oh [__] like
I really got some like lifechanging
momentum that could go you know we've I
mean you've seen a lot of people get hot
and go away get hot die you know what
I'm saying like um are you kind of like
feeling like finally like oh [__] you
know what this is for real like this
this rap shit's really working out for
me yeah hell yeah lately I've been
feeling like that like I've been feeling
like a real artist lady the attention
I've been getting the type of people
that been tapping in now like hell yeah
this [__] like different who tapped in
with you that you were like oh [__] like
this is crazy I was like oh uh estg estg
who W who was sitting in this chair and
stood up and walked off yeah yeah he
stood up and got he didn't like the fact
that I was you probably said buk what
you say bro I asked him what he thought
about aliens yeah and then I asked him
about his football career and he [__]
stood up and watched up football career
he was no he played football he went to
the NFL combine he was like a linebacker
at I think Eastern Kentucky he was like
a like he could have went to the league
yeah he probably I don't think he W I
don't I don't know I just thought the
football thing was like a there's video
of him like [__] in press conferences
like [__] people up on the football
field so I was just asking him about it
and he was like what's that got to do
with my music and I was like but it's
got a lot it's you br I'm asking about
you dog like you know what I'm saying
like yeah D yeah he probably yeah yeah
you wanted to talk about SOG tapped in
yeah he's dope I love his music yeah he
wants to work yeah he told me to send
him something oh that' be hard yeah that
[__] crazy any of the like West Coast LA
ogs hit you at
all
uh no not know West coose G's matter of
fact on the day homie somebody uh on
[__] one of my old managers did tell me
one of this one of them old [__] he
got a know name too cuz I forget right
now cuz I be smoking weed and [__] on
Old like yeah one back from one of them
krub like type eras cuz one of them
[__] cuz you said they want to work me
but I'm like I'm spoty all that [__]
ain't is before your era yeah I respect
it though the de homies I respect the
OG's on like if Snoop hits you Snoop you
know that's different you know that's
leg that's Snoop that's Sno on the D me
but a lot of that [__] I'm just like
know don't be feeling ain't my error but
I respect OG's though um for people who
aren't from La obviously you have
rolling 40s 40s tattooed on your on your
lip people who can't read it um I I
think that the most famous [__] from La
in the last decade is probably nip who
is you know obviously is affiliated with
the rolling 60s um are you guys like
very what's the difference between the
Rolland 40s rolling 60s and well it's
kind of like [__] it's kind of like the
same thing like the 40s well in LA and
the hoods like that's going to be like
the closest hoods going to get to like
damn and near being the same it's like
only a couple shits off from us being
different like we like anything that's
got like rolling in front of it it's
kind of like you n cuz it's like rolling
30s rolling all type of [__] but just
the 40s and the 60s cuz we just like we
just like it just being always you kind
of move in the same direction type [__]
on gang so we just like all acted like
40s and the 60s on game same Ops same
Ops that makes sense okay um was nip
somebody who you grew up like you know
looking up to not necessarily looking up
to cuz but I had like a on the de homies
a couple uh nip songs I used to play on
gang I ain't going to lie I play I I
listen to C more after C FP but I think
the world was
I I mean I've known nip since 09 he was
on my show in 09 but like you know
unfortunately he passed away and then
people really gave him the flowers he
deserved after he di me it made me like
look at certain [__] different and pay
attention to his lyrics a little bit
more on gang but like y' I had a couple
songs like that that was hot though that
I used to play while he was
alive I didn't like you know look up to
him though but he was like on a d Me a
Genius though no for sure one of the
greats man I was I wonder too like it's
it's crazy cuz I feel like um him
passing the way he did like you know was
such a tragic situation cuz he was at
home like for you do you see [__] like
that and like make sure you're kind of
like very very careful cuz now you got a
lot of eyes on you bro yeah hell yeah on
the dead homies bro i' be like paranoid
cuz i' be already like moving a certain
way though on the dead homies I don't
like being a certain place too long I be
like in and out on like cuz I already
know [__] like that can happen I already
know and you're very recognizable I'm
very recognizable everybody already know
your face tattoos are very I mean people
people see you know you you don't know
them they can [__] around car they can
be like innocent looking type [__] you
don't even know see you like oh that's
X4 [__] around text to X4 up here you
don't even know crazy [__] like that so
you're always in and out of places yeah
you got to be in and out bro you'll die
or [__] around in up in a situation
where you got to kill a [__] now you
fight life yeah I noce like a lot of
people like you know for the most part
La if you're it feels like if you're if
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing you're successful in any sort of
way like you just get more hate you know
what I'm saying and not even necessarily
from like who your quote unquote Ops
should be like people from where you're
from yeah hell yeah cuz everybody like
you know they want to be the one they Be
Like That Should Be Me That Should Be Me
type [__] cuz so that's how that should
be and it they always say like if uh
somebody ask you for something you can
say yes 10 times when you say no on the
11th time they take that [__] personal
and then there tell a [__] no that's
that's who you that's they going to
expose what it really is 100% have you
uh had to weed out any of those type of
people around your Camp cuz obviously
like you said like you got you know you
you got you said ex-manager you know so
like have you had to kind of like filter
out any of your immed Circle hell yeah
on the dead homies not really be on it
now on the Dead Homie cuz it's really
like getting serious now so I really
like be inten is high I really be on
[__] I ain't got time for no to keep my
grass cut anybody that's do any type of
bunk snake Vibes get up out of here um
what's what's uh wax involvement with
your career nothing he just like give me
advice and [__] he just called me all
other day too and just told me like you
know I'm [__] high he just like proud of
me and all that type of [__] greaty that
is I love whack man can always like call
him for advice and [__] yeah yeah
whack's a good guy yeah I've been on the
um wrong end of a screaming wack call
before was that right in 20 was it 2015
yeah shout out to Wack he thought I
leaked a song a game song which I didn't
leak well [__] I'll probably react the
same way I somebody my song I was living
in Florida at time like yo what how the
[__] I got the song bro like I'm living
in Florida dog
like he was he's like I have my team of
hackers and they know that you're the
one that leaked it and I'm like bro what
what what hackers you got dog hey but
then he's got these Clubhouse detectives
you never know [__] it's crazy uh um man
hey which tattoo hurt the
most uh this one right here cuz I got
this [__] picked in jail cuz oh
so it was like like pick I got to sit
there and get that [__] like
little line by line yeah I got to re hit
again when I got out but the originally
that's kind of how they would be doing
that [__] in like uh the old days right
H yeah so what is it what what do they
use is it a need it's like uh yeah like
a little needle cuz on the D really like
a little staple a staple it's like a
staple cup but they make it as you know
in cuz all type of creative smart ass
people You' be surprised no no for sure
I saw them doing Habachi in jail so
[__] like staple cut guitar string or
whatever on the D homies and they put it
on rap it however the [__] rap it do
what they do do [__] are they like make
a get some batteries wherever the [__]
connect that up to make that run how
that run and do what they do [__] great
that sounds terrible on gang how many of
your tattoos did you get in jail uh most
of them most of them yeah damn did was I
I always say you know my cousins are all
in PR and uh they are all fully tattooed
and they would always be like you know
the guys who could do tattoos in prison
like they're kind of like a hot
commodity you know what I'm saying like
yeah oh yeah cuz everybody be wanting to
get tatted and [__] so everybody wants
to get tatted so you kind of like got to
you know slide them some some food or
you know some bread on the outside
whatever it is you know the tattin area
hell yeah you going to make you going to
run it up you can run it up in jail [__]
off a lot of [__]